do you have any biological samples in
your possession
no
i don't i don't
um
i was offered some biological samples
these are the some of the so-called
implants
but when i started asking questions
about the um
the providence of these things i and the
first one was
well where
where's the consent forms from the
patient
right and um because you can't just go
running willy-nilly with pieces of
people's bodies or things out of
people's bodies that first of all don't
have consent forms
uh second of all
uh and that's for both hipaa as well as
other reasons i'm about to tell you
which is
that
you know let's say that somebody takes a
nodule out of somebody's arm
well who's to say it's not cancer did
you send it to a pathologist for review
none of these things were done with most
of these things and i i realized that
the person who realized who took out
some of these things was themselves a
doctor
but they probably should have known
better
you know because if these days something
goes wrong and that person gets cancer
even if it wasn't that thing wasn't
cancer somebody could quite rightly ask
you
did you test that how do you know that
that wasn't uh a initiating cancer and
the person died of a metastasis
so you're at fault
so the materials that i
uh were sent was sent at one point after
i asked that question within a few days
i sent it right back
and said no
i mean would i love to be able to get a
handle on biological materials
absolutely because i can go through all
of the testing that i know how to do in
fact i'm probably better at biological
materials than i am at metals
are you able to test if it's cancer like
you are you able to test now even though
oh years later oh yeah yeah i mean as
long as
as long as it's been preserved i can't i
sent it back but you know the other
thing is that you you can't
if i don't have a consent form from the
patient
and in some cases some of these let's
say objects are are so
old if you will
uh that there is no consent form and
then you'd have to go to the family
members to get consent
because the people are public
and often and the names are public
and you know the families might not want
to be besmirched so you know you just
got to be very careful with all of this
stuff
you know and i think i learned it i i
learned this uh most through the the
atacama exercise
um
that even though i didn't think it was
uh
i thought that it was probably like a
monkey or something like that when we
found out conclusively that anacomba was
human
well that's when
the ethicists descended and moss
to say well you should have known well
you didn't know first of all but
secondly um you know
there were no consents from family which
was you know that's right but you know
i i i didn't take the thing and i didn't
uh i didn't um
know what it was at the beginning but
now people know conclusively and they
can do what they want with that data and
i think give the give the young girl a
proper
resting but that's a whole other issue
altogether but i mean it does tell you
that you know you can walk into areas
thinking you're doing good and uh you
know when you find out the truth if you
will then people will
decide based on the truth what you
should have done even before you knew it